we haven't obviously been able to see
um friends um
a time when you know that probably quite
useful
being pregnant in normal times can be
stressful
but imagine being told you weren't
allowed to see friends or family
when the baby you were expecting doesn't
survive
or that you are at a higher risk of
contracting a potentially deadly virus
simply because of the color of your skin
it's over it was overwhelming it was
really overwhelming we are
going on a social distance when even the
simple things we take for granted
are restricted there's a second walk
we've been on
our parents won't get to meet um
our newborn baby these are the stories
of pregnancy and birth
in the pandemic
[Music]
my name is kat i'm a journalist for sky
news
who happens to be seven months pregnant
as we look back on the last few months
of lockdown
i've been speaking to pregnant women who
like me
are going through a crucial time of
their lives in the pandemic
it is like you do you do feel really
vulnerable um
i think it all compounds with each other
like if you can't necessarily go out
just to do the normal things like food
shopping you would overthink things that
you perhaps wouldn't
wouldn't normally do it does feel like
you're doing it on your own a bit
because you have to
yeah go to these appointments on your
own where's it gone
a magician never reveals her feet
not being able to share the joys with
family my family haven't literally only
saw her
last week that for me was tough
[Music]
we don't actually know exactly how many
babies have been born in lockdown
because many haven't been registered yet
but it could be
up to a quarter of a million for most
the experience of pregnancy and birth
will have been different
but not dangerous yes things have
changed but in essence
you will still be getting your maternity
care you will be
seeing your midwife regularly if you
need to be referred on to see an
obstetrician because things are slightly
more complicated
then that will happen just doing some
batch cooking for
when baby arrives for some
this period has made a bad situation
much worse
jess watson was seven months pregnant
when the lockdown was announced
but at that time it wasn't her biggest
worry
just three months earlier she had been
told her baby had just
a 50 50 chance of survival he
had a congenital diaphragmatic hernia a
condition called
cdh which is basically a hole
in the diaphragm which allows the other
organs
to push up into the chest space when
lockdown happened
um it was sort of even harder we didn't
have that support
system with our families and our friends
around us getting close to the due date
um and obviously there was a lot of
changes
within individual hospitals in terms of
who would be allowed at the birth um so
that was something that we were we were
worried about
we tried to change our breath plan
that's okay we got around that
however um we had a small hiccup
yesterday our maternity unit had changed
its guidelines things are changing all
the time so we
try to keep up to date a couple of weeks
before i gave birth
i even got a phone call from my midwife
saying that all home births were
cancelled
i was so upset because they couldn't be
supported by the ambulance services
a survey of senior midwives found that
29
had been forced to close midwife-led
birthing units
these units are recommended for low-risk
pregnancies as evidence shows women are
less likely to receive interventions
like epidurals but the outcomes for
babies are the same
most hospitals began to only allow one
birthing partner
who had to leave soon after the birth
we are on our way to the hospital to
hopefully
have a baby and if today's weather's
anything to go by it is
almost 15 16 degrees already it's
looking like a beautiful day and we
don't want you to hang around
leo was born at 2 38
on the um 8th of may and
um they told us obviously like it said
that
um they would sort of paralyze him
sedate him as soon as he was born
and so we wouldn't be we wouldn't hear
him cry he wouldn't make any sound when
he was born
um but he had other ideas apparently um
and um he was born screaming
which was actually quite wonderful
because we didn't actually think we
would
get to hear his voice
when i was pregnant with my daughter it
was a really exciting time whereas this
time
it's quite uh anxiety inducing you know
stepping into a hospital
or into a gp surgery um everyone being
masked up in ppe
i am just over 38 weeks pregnant with my
second
boy okay tomatoes
tomatoes yeah onion
yeah we've never had this much time
together as a family and we're never
going to get that time
back we're never going to get it again
unless this lockdown happens again which
let's hope it doesn't
while families have adapted to the
restricted services
involving others in virtual ways it's
been tough to keep track of what is and
isn't available for those most at risk
it could be fatal women who are black or
from a minority ethnic background
are already five times more likely to
die during childbirth than white women
a recent report found that in the uk men
and women from black and asian ethnic
groups are up to twice as likely as
white people to die
if they contracted the virus and of the
pregnant women who have been admitted to
hospital after contracting covert 19
55 were black or from an ethnic minority
so prosperities is a social maternal
well-being social enterprise
which supports mums it's emotional
support
so being that friend if they need a
friend or you know a sister or someone
to listen to their
troubled stress but it's also that
education support so
telling them that they must go to the
hospital or they must call their
midwives
if they are worried many of the women
clatilled works with
feel they aren't listened to this lack
of trust has made the pandemic
even more dangerous for them
so i actually run um a
mother's group called mums and tea where
we're all black women we all come
together we share our experiences and
anecdotally
a lot of women have had the same sort of
experience as i have
feeling that they just haven't been
listened to feeling like you know
they've just been left to get on with it
having to labor without any pain relief
because
of this notion of you know you're strong
you can do it
going into the hospitals knowing that
pregnant black pregnant women are more
likely to
um be admitted for coronavirus
um symptoms it's just it was just
if i tell it's over it was overwhelming
it was really overwhelming
just knowing that i was more at risk
that just always put that put the fear
in me because it's like oh you know
am i safe is this okay should i be
wearing ppe
how am i gonna breathe under all the you
know the masks and everything
um is it safe you know it's just
yeah it's it's a lot and i was
definitely filled with a lot of anxiety
it's messy and it'll probably be really
annoying in the middle of the night
trying to change your nappy
in here with all this mess i'll be the
first grandchild and my mum's only child
as well
she's very excited but i know she's very
sad
um because the realization is that she
won't be able to
see her grandchild or
have a cuddle have a hold we are
going on a social distance walk today
with my mom never mind the change
in birth preference i think that that is
going to be the hardest thing is the
fact that
um our parents won't get to meet
our newborn baby these factors have led
to an increase in worry
stress and anxiety not just for parents
who are expecting
but also after the birth there was a 75
increase in calls to the postnatal
depression advice and support helpline
within the first week of the lockdown
announcement
the lack of face-to-face support has
left many feeling isolated at a critical
time in their lives
and their babies
open about my feet the next morning and
the midwives wheeled me down in a
wheelchair
to the nicu to see leo
unfortunately by that point he'd started
to
deteriorate he wasn't stabilizing his
oxygen levels
were never at a point where they were
happy with them
they were able to move him into a side
room for us
take him off the noisy ventilator keep
all the drugs going still he was still
comfortable and still kind of unaware
really
um i mean he knew and we know he knew we
were there because when we were changing
his nappy
and his heart rate was spiking and the
nurse said to us it's he's responding
to your touch which um was really nice
and really comforting
to know that he knew we were there when
we were ready
they disconnected the ventilator
completely
and he he went peacefully
with us both with us both there
it's been isolating in the sense that we
haven't
obviously been able to see friends
um a time when
you know that probably quite useful
to have a distraction or to you know
have
somebody else to talk to um about what's
what's been happening and and also to
share
to share leo with other people um
we haven't really had the chance to to
do that properly either
so that's what we're we're just in the
in the middle of planning his funeral at
the moment and
um we're only allowed
six of us there um
so again extended friends and and family
um
won't be able to join us
which again is is like i said it's it's
difficult because you can't you sort of
don't feel like
you're able to share um
that with them in the same in the same
way
um
which is yeah strange
we all face continued uncertainty about
what the future will look like
but for those who have been through
heartbreak suffered with mental health
issues
or simply haven't been heard during a
crucial time in their lives
the true impact may take a long time to
recover from
hi nicole here again and i am now with
baby george he
was due on the 22nd of may but um
fancied keeping us waiting until june
but he's really good we're all really
good